so this is CES
I'm here at CES and Microsoft CEO Steve
Ballmer just wrapped up his keynote
speech the first one he's ever done at
this trade show the big news of his
speech was Windows 7 will be available
for a free download the beta version of
Windows 7 starting in just a couple days
now why is that good news well two words
Windows Vista and the reason this is so
important is because Windows Vista
basically has irritated people to no end
Vista has it's an incredible resource
hog it didn't run on a lot of people's
computers they had to upgrade their RAM
and do other kinds of things and then
there were all those incessant security
notifications are you sure you want to
install this software are you sure you
want to put that disc in the drive are
you sure you want to click on this link
it was enough to drive a person crazy so
fortunately Microsoft has listened to
the critics and their next version of
Windows Windows 7 will be much leaner
faster it will even run on netbooks
which is a really good thing and it has
a lot less of those annoying pop-up
security notifications other
promising-looking things about this
operating system include a revamped
taskbar it's sort of transparent in a
way that sort of resembles what you
might have seen on another certain
company's operating system Mac and lets
you do some nifty things like you can
dock your favorite applications down
onto the taskbar and you can access them
with a single click or right click to
see your most recent files in that
application there are some other cool
things about it too like easier home
networking easier management of the
devices that you plug into your computer
and generally they're just trying to
make it a much easier faster slicker
experience for people using Windows
another big thing that Microsoft showed
was Windows Live it's finally out of
beta now this is the online service of
applications that Microsoft provides
that you can use to access your
documents and your music and your email
and your calendars and so forth from
anywhere you are on the web it's a
really important part of Microsoft
strategy because they see the day coming
when nobody really cares what kind of
computer they're running or what
operating system it's running all they
want to do is sign on and check their
mail Microsoft is dearly hoping that
that won't be Gmail but that's why
they've got Windows Live the company
also announced a bunch of other things
in the
gaming area they showed some cool R&D
stuff including this nifty flexible
display that I think personally was fake
but who knows they showed some cool
stuff Microsoft clearly has the time the
money and the interest to do R&D
Microsoft actually spent 8 billion
dollars on R&D last year Ballmer said
and that's a ton of money it allows them
to do all kinds of innovative stuff and
come up with new technologies that you
may see 5 or 10 or 20 years down the
line I just wish that they would show
more truly interesting stuff instead of
just playing catch-up like they seem to
be doing all the time